le président de la république doit
recouvrer la raison est respectée les
acquis de la révolution de 2011 et notre
constitution de 2014 c'est par ces mots
que ghazi chaouachi présidente du parti
le courant démocrate a commencé son
discours devant un parterre de
journalistes tunisiens et étrangers
quatre partis d'opposition ont organisé
ce matin une conférence de presse
conjointe pour fustiger les mesures
exceptionnelles annoncées par le chef de
l'état lors de son discours de sidi
bouzid le 22 septembre dernier kaïs
iedge avait dévoilé les contours de sa
feuille de route tant attendu depuis son
coup de force du 25 juillet annonçant
entre autres la prolongation des mesures
d'exception et le gel du parlement pour
une durée indéterminée tout en abrogeant
une partie de la constitution tunisienne
des dispositions exceptionnelles
concentrant les pouvoirs exécutif et
législatif entre les seules mains du
président de la république pour
l'opposition une telle violation de la
constitution représente un danger pour
la démocratie
il appelle le chef de l'état au dialogue
national seule issue à une sortie de
crise qui doit selon eux être réglé avec
toutes les forces politiques du pays
sans ingérence étrangère référence aux
visites des 4 et 10 septembre dernier à
tunis deux délégations américaine et
européennes écouter
le message que nous adressons au
président de la république et que la
tunisie est dans une situation de crise
sans précédent et nous craignons de
perdre les acquis démocratiques nous a
permis la révolution nous sommes dans
une optique de réconciliation afin de
soigner la politique tunisienne rongé
par la gangrène et les défaites à
répétition sur le président de la
république vous n'avez pas le droit de
gouverner seul de concentrer tous les
pouvoirs entre vos mains et de suspendre
la constitution
c'est un vrai problème quand le chef de
l'état ferme les portes du palais de
carthage aux forces politiques aux
personnalités tunisiennes tout en
rompant le dialogue et de l'autre côté
les ouvrir aux diplomates étrangers pour
discuter avec eux des problèmes
politiques de notre pays cette crise
doit d'être gérés en interne entre
tunisiens
même son cloche pour les leaders des
partis est à cape town et afek tounes
qui craignent une dérive autoritaire du
pouvoir et un enlisement de la crise
politique et économique pour fadel abdel
kafi chef du parti afek tounes et ancien
ministre des finances la crise politique
que traverse la tunisie a entraîné une
dégradation de la situation économique
dans le pays et coûté un homme politique
qui doit être capable de donner des
solutions pratiques à sa population
aujourd'hui il ya eu certainement une
dégradation extrêmement grave de la
situation des finances publiques je vous
donne juste un chiffre la tunisie a
quintuplé sa dette en dix ans la crise
libanaise a été déclenchée par une crise
tout d'abord politique pendant des mois
et des mois on a eu du mal à former des
gouvernements à installer un chef du
gouvernement aujourd'hui la tunisie est
incontestablement dans une situation de
très grande fragilité des finances
publiques à côté il ya très peu
d'investissements privés et nous sommes
nous pouvons être dans le scénario
libanais surtout après tout et
dégradations que nous avons eu des
principales agences de notation dans le
monde depuis l'allocution présidentielle
du 20 septembre dernier de plus en plus
de partis politiques ont dénoncé
l'abrogation d'un pan de la constitution
par le chef de l'état mettant en garde
contre le retour à la tyrannie sans pour
l'heure être parvenu infléchir la
position de cailly sayed qui continue de
faire cavalier seul faisant fi de toute
critique et appelle au dialogue dans la
tente de nouvelles déclarations carthage
annoncé que le chef de l'état se
chargera de l'élaboration de projets
d'amendements relatifs aux réformes
constitutionnelles
avec l'aide d'une commission créée aussi
par décret présidence